[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
welcome to
probably my favorite video to do every
year welcome to the smartphone awards
2020. so 2020 was of course a very
different year a lot of crazy stuff
happened but you know what
tech didn't really stop even events
didn't really stop we kept having these
virtual events and there was constant
new product announcements there's more
videos more reviews than ever this year
and there's more shapes and sizes
than ever before on this table of 2020
smartphones in front of me so that's why
at the end of the year we like to look
back over everything and give out some
awards for some of the best some of the
most interesting some of the most
influential stuff that came out during
the year
it's always like late late during the
year there's even been other youtubers
putting on jackets sitting in front of
tables full of stuff and giving out
trophies to their favorite products
which is actually kind of flattering i
love that that's actually a thing that's
happening now but this is it this is the
one you've been waiting for let's say
this is the smartphone awards
2020. so for those who are new here the
way we do this is we've got a bunch of
categories and for each category there's
going to be a winner and then if there's
any worthy maybe a runner-up and some
honorable mentions but really we'll
focus on that winner all the categories
are time stamped below if you want to
skip around but maybe just grab the
popcorn sit back relax
and enjoy the show so let's get right
into it with the first category which is
the best
big smartphone so most phones
are pretty big already nowadays but i
like to reward what i would call the
best use of space so if you're going to
carry like a genuinely huge phone you
want it to have the best use of that
extra space you've got to have a big
screen it's got to have a big battery
and a lot of big features taking
advantage of that space
and there's a lot of competitors in that
category this year a lot of really big
phones but the winner overall for the
best big phone of 2020
is gonna go to this guy right here this
is the xiaomi me 10 ultra so congrats to
xiaomi on their first smartphone award
ever they made an absolute monster phone
this year this was like the 120 phone it
had a 120x zoom on that camera a 120
hertz display on the front and 120 watt
fast charging included in the box that's
the fastest i've ever seen in a phone
that's supposed to get you 40 battery in
five minutes of being plugged in which
is ridiculous and it's also got a bunch
of other high-end top-end features like
50 watt wireless charging it's got a 4
500 milliamp hour battery half a
terabyte of storage and pretty much
every other high end spec you could
imagine
now they also made a nice little one of
one mkbhd edition i don't know if you
can see that that is pretty cool but
also this phone is only sold in china so
there's a little asterisk on that if you
have to import it to get it that's maybe
what you're into but there are some
runner-ups that should definitely be
recognized now i think a no-brainer for
this category is also
samsung galaxy note 20 ultra another
huge phone with a lot of really big
features they fit the stylus on the side
of the phone again 4 500 milliamp hour
battery huge camera system huge display
and a notorious competitor in the big
phone category i'm also going to give a
shout out a little mention to the asus
where is it on the table the rog phone 3
oh no
i can't find it there's so many phones
here yeah here it is okay rg phone three
we already know this phone's got a
gigantic battery it's also got a huge
front-facing speaker system which you
really don't see often in most phones
this year and so you have to give it
props for that if it's using the extra
space the way big phones should that's
worth recognizing
all right
on to the next category all right so
next up is the best compact phone of the
year this is kind of like the opposite
so most phones are big it's actually
kind of rare to see a great
compact small
flagship level smartphone
and so because there's still a market
for it we like to reward when that's
done well this one
i think is actually a little closer than
you might expect
but the winner for best compact
smartphone of 2020
is the iphone 12 mini so i feel like
this is the no brainer pick right it's
the same as all the rest of the other
iphones
but smaller so same cameras same display
tech same chip same ram same software
same pretty much everything materials
just a smaller phone so it's a flagship
but smaller and that's what this is all
about to some way it kind of represents
a sort of a little mini rebirth of this
category of compact flagships and
hopefully others will follow there's
people with small hands and small
pockets out there give them a great
phone they deserve to have a small great
phone now why was this closer than you
might expect
well
there's actually a flagship phone that
came out this year on this table in
front of me
that's smaller than the iphone 12 mini
quick pop quiz you might be looking
around like what is he talking about how
is that possible
and that's the runner up which is
the samsung galaxy z flip 2. this little
guy right here folded up
is obviously a much smaller phone
than when it's open but it is a compact
phone and it's so it's the big phone in
a small body theory it's kind of the
whole point of a folding phone and this
alternate form factor movement is
enabling things like this and the z-flip
2 was one of the most well-liked folding
phones ever it has a normal aspect ratio
when it's open and it opens up to be a
pretty big phone actually 6.7 inches but
when it folds down and fits in your
pocket or your bag it is smaller than
anything else i love that and i'm really
looking forward to seeing other future
versions of this that'll inevitably have
even better specs higher fresh rate
display better durability all that fun
stuff so gotta mention that z-flip two
all alright so cameras
we like cameras here so if you're
talking cameras you want the best
overall smartphone camera
turns out there's actually a lot of
really good smartphone cameras on this
table here to the point where the
difference between them could come down
to preference as we showed with the
blind smartphone camera test
but
if you had to ask me if i'm going on a
trip
remember those if you're going on a trip
and you can only take one smartphone
camera for all of your photos and videos
there really is still just one winner
here
and that is the iphone
12 pro max that is the winner for best
smartphone camera 2020. so look a lot of
people care about camera the best
smartphone camera of the year this year
just from its prowess across the board
with photos and videos and versatility
goes to this highest end iphone and
they've reclaimed their crown it's just
hard to beat overall and i will say and
i've definitely said in the past i do
like some photos from some other phones
almost just as much and sometimes even
more than the iphone shots but the
iphone takes great editable photos
consistently in the addition of pro raw
in the last few weeks with a software
update took it to another level as far
as image manipulation and then in the
video world the iphone leveled up again
they've always had the best video
quality in any smartphone and now
there's more hdr options better
stabilization and a bigger sensor in the
12 pro max so it's a no brainer this is
the best overall smartphone camera
package my runner-up shout outs are
going to be first of all you might see
this coming as i've mentioned the pixel
5 still often takes photos that i prefer
over the iphone's photos and if i had to
only take one for stills photos
i would take pixel 5. so i definitely
want to mention that and i want to give
a shout out to the blind smartphone
camera test winner for 2020 which was
the asus zenfone 7 pro if you watched
that video it was a bit of a surprise
winner but not so surprised it's got a
new triple camera system on the back
that just so happens to swivel over and
become i think the best selfie camera
system in any phone so shout out to
those two runner ups but we definitely
have a clear winner for the cameras
which is that iphone all right best
battery this should be a pretty easy
objective award to give basically the
phone that nets you the best overall
battery life is gonna win although this
year there's a little more to it there's
some fast charging to consider there's
charging technologies but basically the
winner here is going to be the one that
combines the best battery with the best
software the best features
and the winner is in fact the thick boy
himself without even needing wireless
charging
it's the asus rog phone 3. this phone
just
won't die so it's one of two phones i
tested this year with the biggest
battery i've ever held in a phone 6 000
milliamp hours and then the software
optimization was on point i had no
problem using it at high frame rate mode
144 hertz and getting two days of
battery but then of course you could
clock it down to 120 get a little more
you could clock it down to 90 hertz get
a little more you could clock all the
way down to 60 hertz and i never felt
the need to do that but if i did i would
not be shocked if this was a three-day
phone so major props to that sort of
modularity and the battery experience
but i'll also give a shout out to the
other phone i tested this year with a
surprisingly thin body and still a six
thousand milliamp hour battery
which is that poco m3
again fantastic battery life and you
know not the same charging tech as the
fast charging in the rog phone
but then also
another quick honorable mention shout
out to the samsung m51 i didn't get my
hands on it this year it was released
exclusively in india but that phone
dropped with a 7 000 milliamp hour
battery and it was somewhere under 500
bucks so i haven't tested it but i'm
pretty sure that one would also be a
battery chain
good looks all right
the design award
so this
is an interesting one we've gotten a lot
of interesting designs of course in 2020
and this is probably the most subjective
highly competitive award on one hand
most phones kind of look
somewhat the same but on the other hand
they're all very different in all kinds
of color and finish and material ways
this used to be just like the best build
quality straight up but then it went to
being my favorite overall design which
includes build quality so for 2020
i don't know it was tough i couldn't
pick a phone
that had a mirror finish
i mean you've seen a lot of fingerprints
in this video already so i i just wanted
something that had a matte option
i couldn't pick a phone that curved the
screen too far over the sides that's
been something i'm not a fan of
and i couldn't pick a phone that had a
really ugly camera bump to my eye
but they kind of all have crazy camera
bumps
so anyway
my design award
for 2020
is gonna go to
the samsung galaxy note 20 ultra so yeah
this was easily the most subjective
award this year and i think i could be
swayed to any number of the runner-ups
that i'm about to mention but i was just
a really big overall fan of the hardware
choices that went into this phone this
year obviously the sweet satin finish on
the back and this gold color i like it's
pretty sweet but also galaxy note has
always been pretty boxy which is my
preference they also flattened out the
display on the front so it doesn't curve
over the edges so much like previous
samsung phones and of course it's now
120 hertz and then with the cameras on
the back they added laser autofocus to
fix the issues with the s20 ultra and
it's a top-notch camera system of course
you might not like the bump but i
honestly didn't like almost any camera
bump this year so this one hardly stuck
out from the others and at least it's
stuck in line with the boxy theme so
yeah i ended up landing on this as my
design award winner for 2020. i was just
drawn a lot to the hardware of this
phone even though i'm not the biggest
fan of samsung software i would just
keep coming back to wanting to use
this note 20 ultra so that's a great
design
uh but there's a couple honorable
mentions first of all i have to give a
shout out to my favorite back of a phone
i think of all time
which is pretty high praise but huawei
p40 pro every time i pick up this phone
it's got this nice soft touch back it's
this like iridescent silver look to it
uh
i love the back of this phone i wish
every phone had some sort of version of
this material
uh
yeah it's great couldn't not mention it
and i also want to give a little mini
award there's no trophy for it but a
little mini award to a new recognition
for 2020 which is best hinge
because hinges are so important in all
these alternate form factors we had
swiveling we had vertical hinges we had
backwards hinges forwards hinges
there's a lot of hinges happening on
this table uh but my favorite hinge
of 2020
is the one found in microsoft surface
duo
with the magnets and this thin form
factor this body
this it's
for all the things this phone didn't get
quite right the one thing they
absolutely ace nailed was the hinge and
the weight of it and this folding
experience and just for that reason
alone
i'm really looking forward to the next
version of this thing and then favorite
crazy design just kind of you kind of
have to give it the recognition i don't
even have it on this table it didn't
ship it wasn't even a real phone but i'm
going to mention it anyway xiaomi mi mix
alpha
that thing kind of took it to the next
level this is the one with the crazy
wrap around display like all right you
want to start curving the display around
the sides of the phone let's just fast
forward a couple years and see what it
looks like with the screen wrapping all
the way around the back we got to
actually see what that was like this
year and we learned a lot from it so
yeah lots of great designs this year
like i said it was pretty subjective
could easily go to any others that are
maybe a little more
subjective to your taste but i gave it
to the one that i think made the best
most overall correct decisions
all right best
budget phone
of 2020
this category heated up a lot i mean
there's a lot of phones on this desk
here that really earn their spot because
of their price to performance ratio and
you know everyone has a different
definition of budget for some it's a
certain price range for me
i want to reward a winner that really
brings a good amount of stuff from the
high-end expensive experience
down to a phone that's lower in price
that's what makes a good budget phone
for me it's got to be an overall good
experience for the buyer at the end of
the day so the winner for best budget
phone of 2020
that's gonna be
the google pixel
4a this was a killer phone it was kind
of a surprise hit actually that google
found with this a line starting with a
3a from last year now you get the 4a at
349 and it gets you that world-class
camera the a1 google software experience
for android and overall decently
well-built phone for literally less than
half of the price of a lot of
comparables out there plus a headphone
jack it's really good this turned out to
be easily one of the best phones to
recommend anywhere under 400 bucks so
that's quality my runner-up is also a
phone that was a budget version of an
expensive line so again you're seeing
high-end stuff brought down in price
and uh i'm gonna give a shout out to the
iphone
se
solid runner up here so this was 400
bucks and it was rocking the same
world-class chip the same spec as the
flagship iphones at the time and the
same familiar iphone software experience
but again decently well built the design
is a bit dated of course as they move
away from phones with fingerprint
readers but you do get metal and glass
here but they did get rid of the
headphone jack and i feel like i can't
give a winner of best budget phone to a
phone that
got rid of the headphone jack out of
principle
but i do also want to give a quick shout
out to a runner-up
in the best budget space and that's
going to be oneplus nord this phone was
a little less of like trying to bring
something bleeding edge from the top
down in price but more of being a
quality overall budget experience so i
think they made a great set of choices
to keep price low but deliver a
consistently really nice phone so a lot
of people are going to like the nord for
that reason no headphone jack on this
phone either but again solid bang for
the buck but like i said off the top
it's really hard to go wrong in this
category heat it up a lot you've got the
the moto g series the samsung a series
we've got the poco phones there's a lot
going on cheap phones are getting good
like i've said
let's keep that up okay
so
biggest bust of the year
the trophy you hate to have to give but
i don't know there's always something
every year
that
feels like you're rewarding the ones
that do good things and this is sort of
a slap on the wrist of the bad stuff i
mean you already know if your phone's
bad when it comes out but we've had some
notable
losers in the past
winners losers we had htc ultra you had
red hydrogen
you had pixel four
this year
it goes to a phone that actually wasn't
that bad of a phone
it just had a horrific launch strategy
and a terrible price
you probably know where i'm going with
this this is a
samsung galaxy note 20. this is the bust
of the year for sure now samsung is
usually pretty good at putting together
a compelling package for a smartphone at
each price point but the note 20
launching at a thousand bucks seemed
very out of character basically
launching it alongside the note 20 ultra
to kind of justify its higher price
but note 20 with its plastic back with
its 1080p
60hz display with its non-expandable
storage like this phone was absolutely
never worth a thousand bucks and it
deserves the nope 20 title couldn't
recommend it now today you can go on
amazon and get this phone for 7.99 which
is closer to about right but yeah when
this guy launched it was definitely a
miss pretty uncharacteristic from
samsung
but that's why it's uh the bust of the
year just never really landed also
honorable mention to the escobar fold 2
which i also don't have on this desk
because it is in the possession of the
fbi someday i'll be able to tell that
story all right
most improved award mip
2020
and there's really only one phone if i'm
being real that actually deserves this
one see phones typically we get a little
bit of an improvement each year maybe a
faster chip maybe a little bit of a
better camera maybe it's got a little
refreshing the design you see some some
cool stuff year over year but sometimes
this most improved award goes to the
biggest jump from a terrible phone the
year before
this is none of those things this is
just a straight up significantly better
phone than last year let's just get to
it most improved phone of 2020
is definitely samsung galaxy z fold 2.
this is the epitome of 2nd gen games
generation 2 of a new form factor is
when you expect to see the most
improvement and samsung definitely
delivered that here huge improvement on
the front display going from a candy bar
bezel afterthought to a real usable full
screen phone and huge improvements on
the inside display going from a notched
slightly ugly setup to this thinner
bezeled notchless 120hz display that's
just a joy to use it's one of my
favorite phones of the year for sure and
it's a clear runaway favorite for the
2020 most improved award but i do want
to give
an honorable mention though
to a
a phone that didn't really actually get
better
but you could argue
delivered a better experience
pixel 5 right so last year was pixel 4's
bust of the year pixel 5 turns around
comes back gets you a same camera
a worse processor arguably and removes
some features like project solely and
the image processing chip but for some
reason pixel 5 landed at a sweet spot in
price and was just a more understood
package it didn't have to compete
against the crazy high-end ultra stuff
in the same way
and for that reason
i'll give it a little recognition the
phone isn't necessarily dramatically
better than last year
it's actually worse but it was much
better marketed and it landed the right
way good work so that brings us to
our final award
of the night the biggest award
it's the mvp
the big one uh this is drifting back
into
subjective award territory instead of
objective you know this could be
my favorite overall phone doesn't
necessarily have to be the one that puts
up the biggest best numbers
but it's the phone that maybe had the
biggest impact on what happened this
year it's the phone that maybe was the
best overall combination of things maybe
it's the phone that was in my pocket
but it's the mvp and it deserves to be
recognized to sort of represent the year
in phones
and so with that
my mvp for 2020 smartphone of the year
is going to
the samsung
galaxy s20
fe the fan edition this is an award for
its impact on this new premium mid-range
tier that really broke out this year and
for absolutely nailing it so when you
look back at this phone the way it
launched and the way it was reviewed it
was pretty quiet you know not super
flashy it's a samsung flagship launching
somewhere in the middle of their range
with a pretty nice feature set right but
now that we've sort of collectively
realized that this awesome price
category has gotten so good this this
premium mid-range like 700 thing
happening you know iphone 12 drops right
in there pixel five slots right in there
one plus eight eight pro slot right in
there there's a lot of action at this
new price
this phone with its spec sheet and its
features is virtually indistinguishable
from a flagship it nailed it this
phone's 6.99 and it has 120 hertz oled
display flagship spec and it's flat
which is great the phone has a high-end
triple camera system which is great it
has a snapdragon 865 a flagship chip and
six or eight gigs of ram that's awesome
and the phone has a 4500 milliamp hour
battery toss in ip68 water resistance
toss in 5g toss in fast charging toss in
wireless charging
i mean it's complete really the only
thing you could complain about is this
back it's a plastic back
but it is a matte finish it's less
likely to shatter i think a lot of
people love to complain about plastic
but this had a couple new colors and was
actually a pretty nice implementation of
it this phone's launch made the galaxy
note 20 look stupid like this was an
actual an actual flagship killer more of
a flagship killer than a lot of the
other stuff that's claimed to be over
the years
this was the shining light of this new
premium mid-tier breakout category of
the year and uh pretty much nailed
everything about it galaxy s20 fe
well done i guess that's what you get
when you're you have a samsung
you know
in this whole category they throw a
bunch of stuff at the wall to see what
sticks some of it really sticks in the
form of an mvp
some of it really doesn't stick in the
form of the bust of the year but they
have a most improved they have all kinds
of stuff going on
but i don't know i think it all kind of
comes down to a lot is still happening
in the smartphone world and next year is
shaping up to be
well maybe even more interesting than
this year we get a lot of generation
twos next year we get a lot of potential
most improves next year
and uh with any luck we'll see a bunch
more matte phones too of course i do
like to give my honorable mentions to
the mvp category so i will mention the
phone that i have kept in my pocket the
longest this year which is the oneplus 8
pro since it came out early in the year
this has been
sort of my steady
phone that i returned to
great camera system great battery the
only thing i really don't like about it
is this screen curving over the edges
but software experience battery life
wireless charging they finally made a
flagship and it turned out great love
that
and my iphone 12 pro has been in the
other pocket
but yeah that's
that's the smartphone awards for 2020.
so with that it's been an honor to be
your host for this year enjoy the rest
of your evening
good night
[Music]
you